typographic care to correct on the Panda
as you'll soon discover bite by the
change of style these notes are actually
bye bye Tracy no no I don't know how you
people in a I would write a computer
program would determine which which ta
read wrote which thing I I suppose the
main ways to tell you to look at the
spelling of a few words like behavior ah
ok no no that's what I mean there's
british spelling an American spy ok now
today I said I was I I would talk about
pictures illustrations trying to
especially with respect to computer
science but by popular request people
said they wanted to see my my very first
publication where I broke into where I
broke into print well actually actually
I I actually got into readers digest
this year but that's but this is but the
first one this is from readers discussed
and this is the where they they have the
Encyclopedia Britannica on pages 144 and
43 we know know in the time the front
cover of this wasn't you know this is my
first and I was a co-author with Ernie
Kovacs and you anybody ever hear of him
since nineteen fifty-seven and let's see
science department page 36 here we go so
now this on I got 25 bucks for this
article $25 yes I I became rich
immediately and so so this was this was
it and and I sent in just a mini a draft
I gave them a mimeograph hand out just
for the heck of it because I had based
the system of weights and measures on
things from that magazine had no idea of
publication
and and I believe this I this joke here
was was actually ripped off from Roger
price anyway this is the but it was
wonderful illustrations since we're
talking about pictures today we had
probably the best you know up until the
tech book it was the best illustrated
thing I ever wrote and it's very logical
system it's all it's all based on you
see here's the the units of length and
the fish remote putters DB is the very
small one day the you got volume mass
everything in there in fact time was
also decimal this was the main app the
main innovation that instead of having a
365-day year we had a 100-day year this
makes it much easier for calculations
and your birthday comes more often so
and and and this was something that they
completely changed because I had named
the units of time after the editors of
Mad Magazine the original Mad Magazine
harvey kurtzman and his and his gang but
they they had all recently left and
counted a new magazine called humbug and
and so all the new editors were named
who got named it units of time named
after them and we started with October
one nineteen fifty two basic was when
they time system goes and so on and then
since everything was so logical
everything was very decimal so I also
had I felt there was a need for
something else and so I i introduced the
unit of counting oh well that was my
first excursion again
I on my Vita yes this is number one my
Vita all right i also used it i also
used it on my boat boys i ran for
student government and i lost miserably
but I you know I use this as part of my
run my campaign but didn't help ok so
just writing from ad pay better than
writing technical attic yes I think the
next time I got any money was about 15
years later there's a the ACM computing
surveys used to pay five hundred dollars
to two authors for suppository articles
and so that was about nineteen seventy
when I first had another another nickel
from from writing technical articles and
book publishing dad so that's feast or
famine but it's a butt book like Derek
computer programming its it it's more
than my Stanford salary so that there
was that Deb you know that became a
problem as to as to what charities to
support but she was $25 here I think I
you know that was worth a little more in
1957 but not that yeah okay now my
second article was the one I was really
going to show you this was this was in
the communications of the ACM is about
Ren Cibola how it was it revised unified
new compiler ingenious basic language
encoder or something like this we had to
find some word some reason for for every
acronym in those days but Pascal was
just named after Pascal and and so I
wanted to show you this because it's I
think it has it has the worst the most
complicated flow chart in the world this
is the DISA spaghetti a an example of
but I decided to present the entire
algorithm in this chart
and so it it doesn't quite succeed I
don't think I mean yeah although it
would say it's all there really and I I
could prob you know we would do it quite
differently now nowadays yeah this is a
here it goes in fact there's I corrected
an error here this should really go up
there I don't know but that's my own
copy but still the way that I the way
that I explained the algorithm was
something that I still believe is about
as good as I could do and that is his
play-by-play account and so I and so I
gave I so I give a an example that's
somewhere in here non here Isaac isn't
in the kind of programming languages we
had in those days this was on a machine
that had 2,000 words of memory that's a
decimal 10 digit words so that's about
4k bytes of memory and and we that's and
and we couldn't have done it in 1999 but
2,000 was just enough and and but but so
we didn't have identified as we
everything was sub scripted and global
and so you had you and you had you had a
variable C variables and you know y
variables eyes were integers and season
wise where were floating point and and
then you could have constants and
parenthesis and stuff like that but we
didn't go into a lot of parsing and this
I use this example because it a previous
article had come out with with this
example used as to how how it would go
except i added another another minus
sign here because this was you know to
show something something more in
algorithm so now anyway so then a symbol
scan to see this
this is a bottom-up parsing algorithm we
didn't know what at the time but this is
and you know but the main idea is that
we that there is a you can you can you
can play through the flowchart and
follow it but you know the symbol comes
in you started start and symbol comes in
and it tells you you can you can see
here whether you got through the loop
okay and in once a while it would go and
add some machine language to the to the
program and I define the machine
language here and and the final code so
it but may they want to show you here
was that what was this this flow chart
which is something I've overcome sin
still since those days another thing I
had to overcome with I didn't Greek when
I first when I published this paper I
was a junior i guess at college and i
and i had just read this article that
came out in the june issue and i said
hey we know how to how to do it better
than those guys did in the article
they'd publish and they were professors
and so but why didn't we think about
that so much we just thought we had a
neat idea that we would we would want to
want to explain to to other people so I
so I I wrote this up on behalf of the
computing laboratory that I that I was
working part time but I didn't occur to
me to mention any of the other people's
names who are all who are really
responsible for most of this I thought I
was just you know it didn't occur to me
that I was going to be getting credit
for these ideas by publishing and that
was a completely new concept to me at
the time and so are the algorithms that
are described here were really do too
largely to a friend of mine bill lynch
and the flowchart was drawn by another
friend of mine and so on so all i did
was through the writing and and i
thought that you know and a year later I
learned a little bit more about what's
kosher and wine
on and so when I actually refer to this
article in the art of computer
programming someday I have to make make
make it clear that who gets credit for
it and meanwhile I've written much
letters and so on but but I did make
that mistake too and many young authors
have done this have family in there in
the early papers so I should have said I
should have you know has these other
people as co-authors or certainly had
had big big plant acknowledgments to
saying what it is and so several other
young people have done this too when
they when they publish the first article
that you know words they're so
interested in publishing it in getting
the news out that they doesn't occur to
them that that there's also people
giving credit for to authorship which is
which is a I mean some people only write
papers because of the credit but other
people do it without thinking about that
and and this has and so then those of us
who made this mistake tend to go
overboard afterwards and for a while I
had many co-authors did I tell you about
the time polarity she had had the
supporter in the railroad car as a
co-author this is the one of them right
you know what time you had a question no
oh
uh-huh I didn't have a referee report on
this edge for sure this came out in
november and i had written must have
written it or anything now the
bibliography was just the only the only
thing so that i know there wasn't very
much unlike this was sort of the first
article about how to how to do parsing
that that had come out so so at that
time there wasn't much there wasn't much
to say but yeah you're right i don't
have a single lluvia graphic item in
that article in man for example see what
did I bring this for oh yeah now flow
charts aren't completely are completely
obsolete there's still some value to
them and I'll ask especially if they're
small and I guess people know for
example the syntax diagrams when in
Pascal manuals or something in the
appendix there'll be a little little
charts that will tell you it will tell
you what the pass going which is those
charts to end abuse well here's the
first example of such a chart and it was
actually a larger larger thing than mine
then the flow chart that I published but
still index well enough that is possible
now this was this was alcohol 60 or
slightly extended Algol 60 but it was it
actually you could people would hang
this on their wall and they would and
they would use it like a like people use
a condom chemical sequences of periodic
chart for chemistry and this was the
origin of this kind of ideas and so you
had here's your favorite you know my
let's see where's my finger out here yes
okay dummy statement go-to statement you
see right there and I'll go 60 go to
followed by designation expression how
about 60 allows you to go to an
expression where you could could then
find Desmond occasional expression m19
on the chart and so here's 19 and M is
down
here designation expression here we go
designation expression and so it's a
simple designation expression or a which
is a label or switch designator there
were such things as switches old
obsolete features of programming
languages parenthesized as a nation
expression okay baby well you get the
idea i think from this chart pretty
pretty well what this language is
probably better than reading it's in to
explore and so that's something about
charts still you're giving out you're
working on on finite state machine so we
looked at writing now we have a little
example of of the states that you can be
in when you're waiting to get two heads
in a row and and so you won state is you
haven't seen any heads yet in other
states you've seen one head and this
thursday to bingo you've got it and it's
a nice little state transition diagram
so nothing wrong with a little flow
charts like that ok now the the article
the programming pearls article that i
showed you about the about literate
programming was actually a two-part
article this the first part was the part
I gave you in hand out which was a small
example in the second part I was my
solution to to John Bentley's challenge
problem that he he you know I said I
really believe this is the way to write
programs and the only way to this is for
me not to send you a program on on a
topic of my choice but for you to choose
the topic and and enemy right to a
program for it and then when he when he
published that that was in the following
month probably June last year he he
published it together with a with a
review he figured that this is literate
programming there ought to be literary
reviews as well and so so here he went
and and asked our mcilroy to go and and
write a literary critique of the
literate program
like what would Doug say and the and a
point that but I'm not sure this is
Doug's idea or johns but anyway John
found that one thing Mike my second
program was missing was a picture which
would have explained things that I
decided to describe in words I described
I was describing a data structure which
is fairly new to I mean it was something
in Franklin's thesis that I was trying
to promote in this in his program and so
I so and so I describe it in words but I
didn't have a diagram and so John said
wouldn't it be nice to have a diagram in
there to you and there's nothin why I
couldn't come in and win web this you
can you can use anything in tech and
tech it's not hard at all to make a
diagram like this I mean he said it took
if you know a little bit about tech but
what's this laughing going on here in
the fina Calgary we got arrows in la
tech finds the arrowhead cir aren't too
bad but this would now John said here I
types at this picture in our to using
the pic language with reviews tech
features to include such a feature in
his web program so and certainly I could
I could have done that and also in the
in the in the that big book I showed you
the tech program itself I taught a
course out of that book last spring and
and as I was giving lectures and I was
describing the data structures in the
lectures I started drawing diagrams on
my on my pad and and the students said
hey we were nice to have those same
diagrams in the book when it yeah I
agree it didn't seem to me at the time
now at the time I was thinking only
algebraically I was thinking the way to
get into data structure is to know what
the macros are that you need to dig into
it but that's because I already knew the
data structure if I was learning the
data structure for the first time the
diagrams would have helped would have
helped me make that sink in I forgot to
tell you the punch line on Monday I
showed you this diagram that I was proud
of for in the typesetting program
that showed the two things coming
together and when they when the overlap
you had a page fault and no but I failed
to show you one of the referees comments
said the figure was too was too detailed
okay well I just figured heck with it I
don't think it's too detailed but but
for him it was too detailed oh no no my
own my own attitude is the it was a pic
it was something that you could look for
the detail if you wanted to and you
could find it if you didn't neat if you
didn't on it you didn't you didn't have
to but i but I I really believe in
having something work that you can stare
at if you want to for further
information to an ticket to get the idea
I don't think I don't think I could have
gotten across a real example reality of
it with a little less detail example
yeah and I tend to be a person who
prefers manushya I guess you already
know this my lectures in this course
tend to talk about small points rather
than the overall picture probably our
guest lecturers will give you more more
of the overall floor i'll try to think
of the overall back i tend to be
concerned with with little details most
of my life I I mean I even got to the
point where I started designing the ABCs
at the end there so I so I tend to work
on on small details more in it anyway
here's a here's the thing though
pictures of data structures seem to seem
to help to help some people and I guess
especially in this kind of a data
structure it was it was valuable because
it was a a new novel concept link a now
another paper that I wrote with with
regard to tech was about the way the
tech breaks paragraphs in two lines this
is the most interesting algorithm inside
attack and I wanted to present the
algorithm and so it's not not a trivial
algorithm but
want to prevent it with all the bells
and whistles in a in a publication so
this is that this is a paper that I
wrote with Michael class who also did
his thesis in in generalizing the
paragraph making to page making and
placing no figures and things like that
and so we did this this paper where we
surveyed the we surveyed what had gone
on and by the way if you talked about
bibliography here we had a pretty good
bibiana bibliography and this one in
fact it includes quotes from Bernard
Shaw saying what he thought about the
printers that printed his works as far
as like breaking lines is concerned and
things like that so weak so this was
research this was research pretty well
we used weekly examples of fine a fine
printing where this had been done where
you could also look at that the printing
was complicated enough that you could
look at it and figure out sort of what
the guys were doing even though they
didn't explain what they were doing so
that's that's part of part of it okay
but now the main thing main thing was
how to how to describe how to describe
the general problem how to describe the
algorithm and and so first we describe a
data structure for the input so we have
to describe you know some kind of test
data and so here I have a description of
the test data with all parameters here
which which describes in this some test
data 601 things long but the main idea
you can get we have a paragraph here
which we're going to be looking at we're
going to be trying to typeset break it
in two lines it comes from Grimm's fairy
tales happens to be one of the things we
have online it at sale we have we have
if you want text to use as examples we
have Harold and Maude and we have
and we have withering Heights and we
have this Grimm's fairy tales okay so
now this was the first paragraph of
Grimm's first fairy tale and and the
uses for an example and the example that
the thing that's shown in here the
little little triangles show where
hyphens are possible according to our
data so we're giving this you know this
is our this is the test data assume that
we've specified all permissible places
for hibernation and so now that it
becomes a problem of finding the best
way to break this paragraph in two lines
there's little numbers at the right here
to that show how tight the lines are
like a minus means that it's the line is
compressed more than it you know the
space between words are a little tighter
than usual a plus sign this is these are
fine print but the plus sign means that
they've been stretched a little bit and
so you have a + 965 that means that it's
stretched you know this line here cool
fountain is pretty wide the previous
line is minus point 896 is pretty tight
all right I think we showed wow what did
where did we show in oh yeah here we
here was something we had fun getting
getting the type so to do our main goal
is to find a way to avoid choosing any
break points lead two lines in which the
words are spaced very far apart on which
their reckless gather because such
highly distracting hearts and they had
you know okay we had to communicate to
the printers in England about this at
some length but this was a TK now that
they so then we describe so we describe
the input data which there's starts out
with an empty box at the beginning for
the indentation and then the letter
either an inner word space and all this
goes on so if we describe the date we
describe the data then we give examples
of how it's done by Brand X this is this
is called the first fit method which is
the way people usually go about and
break paragraph into line Brand X says
you get to the end of the line and then
and you know you're in it you know blind
by a certain criterion
the next word doesn't fit and nu and
then you stretch it out essentially or
you find the best the best of the two
possibilities if you have to there is
hyphenation to that I think they would
they would get as much as they can I
think the first good method gets gets
taxed it as tight as possible including
hyphenation and then there's the best
fit method which uses some scoring and
it says this did a little distal
different comes out with what they were
a better score that is it would you
compare that to the paragraphs and and
you get it and comes out it comes out
better than than the other one if it
allows some judgment not doesn't package
this type but but will will will loosen
it up if that seems too if that's not if
that's better in some in some what you
call it some way of scoring it for for
goodness and now then then the the
optimal algorithm I described here has
something where if you look at all these
numbers there are fewer glitches in an
altar or not to be better and so now I
now I have these desirability criteria
which is which are called demerits that
are charged to each line and and when
you look at the figure and you you get
numerical scores you can see the big
ones and you see this first fit method
had had that real stretched out line
there that got eight thousand demerits
well the the best fit did all right on
that one but it it had some other you
know but but the optimum fit was able to
avoid all the bad ones after the
beginning well they started out all
three the same and then at a different
width of line we had we had another
another thing now the idea of the
optimum fit method is you go through and
minimize the total number of demerits
you have an algorithm that just finds
the absolute minimum number of demerits
over all possible ways to break that and
it's possible to do this and and the
next thing I did was show a
all right somewhere in ark in the inner
paper I showed I thought I showed it
maybe I missed it excuse me man time out
for a commercial that's the main
illustration I wanted to show you don't
tell me I left it out of the paper maybe
oh yeah I see cuz I because actually I
was I was explaining the algorithm in
detail later on in the paper so here's
the here's the picture that shows now
this particular argue and this is the
way I want to quit what I wanted to get
at how how are we going to describe the
optimum fit algorithm and the end with
and a diagram was a reasonable way to do
it here you start out to start start
here at this dot and then if you've you
had two ways that were reasonable to
break the first line either after the
word a are after the word King I have
another another example here on the
facing page so you can read this but
anyway there so you could eat you can
either put you nose break it here as we
did or after the word King there's a
little line in here which shows up a
permissible well that's another another
another thing but the main idea was it
that if you broke broke after King it
would you know you would pay 1734
demerits that breaking after a you but
you paid 2357 demerits and so the best
fit algorithm would would choose King it
was a better way to do the first line
now then similarly after a you then if
you broke there then then the second
line could break at the end after was if
you broke after King you had only one
reasonable place after so and so then
you have to and so so the best good
algorithm losses right away because it
it you know it makes it you know it
makes a greedy first choice but then
then it's stuck in the second line has
to be bad well well if you will if you
held off and made the first one a little
bit worse you could you could do real
good
the second line and so this makes a this
makes a little picture with of the
possible ways in the main idea is to
find the shortest path from the
beginning down to the end of the
paragraph here at the end of the
paragraph there's lots of things that
you can do because the last line is
billed at the right so so things don't
get very bad on the last night so anyway
that's the and they are so tech as a way
of essentially finding the shortest path
in this maze and then and this this
illustration here showed the list the
paragraph for the data but also put
little lines in showing you suppose you
increase the tolerance and you said a
tech cuts off and says that I'm not
going to look at anything with more than
so many demerits and anything more than
that I'm just going to assume is going
is we're going to be able to get away
without going that way and then if and
make so tech doesn't even consider all
those possibilities but in this one
there's little lines showing the extra
possibilities you would do if you
increase this tolerance and and Toltec
to look at a much larger maze and try to
find the optimum in that take longer to
run but you would be guaranteed to to to
be able to handle some really bad cases
which might come up once in every
thousand times so that's the way I
presented that the algorithm besides the
oh yah we gave you know people also play
with with things so we gave a many
examples here here we gave some examples
of what you do if it if you asked it to
set it with in take extra extra long you
I mean make it three lines longer than
it should be because you really need
somehow this this looks so terrible I
don't see anybody would actually do it
but the algorithm is prepared to do that
if you ask it to stretch out okay so
then we have to present the algorithm
and so we do that in a way that your
apartment right now familiar with a
web-like status before i capitalized
names of
subsection so it looks funny to me now
and and then we also present or describe
a computational experience we give a
chart like this showing the in the
entire volume 2 how did it do or in this
in this book how often did you get this
is a a histogram showing how often you
like 0 here is the means that the spaces
were just at the right at the normal
right this line here is sort of a line I
was set without compressing or shrinking
the spaces and these lines are very
tight up the top these lines are
stretched out at the bottom and so it
then I then I comment at this data is
biased because if I had a paragraph that
really looked bad I probably rewrote it
and so in order to in order to get more
true data I took part of the book and I
retype said it with a different line
width and then I got spaces like this
compared to the out comparing the
optimum fit to the to the other typical
method of people used okay that anyway
this was the this was the way that
algorithm performance was then
demonstrated by by charts and then I
have examples from from Bibles where
think where they had to typeset the
Latin corresponding with the Hebrew with
the same thing and and it's funny that
they saw this all the Bible here they
they they felt it was so important to
have lines the same width that they
filled in a whole bunch of of o's in
here in center but anyway you know we
could look at that a lot of examples
from old printing and find out how and
find out how how new methods compared
and so on so okay
now there was a book that came out
talking about how to present charts that
doc had very good reviews came out about
two years ago and it's it doesn't solve
all the world's problems but it gets to
thinking about the problem of making
good charts and and so if you have a
problem with with the with this I would
recommend that you look at this book and
get to think of get too rough thinking
about it and well the main thing that he
doesn't like is high charts he thinks
that they're completely hopeless but he
gives me he gives many examples so of
things from some reason some otherwise I
guess the best starts now is USA today
isn't it for charge here's one from
Russia and Counting the style plan ok
well there's a book called how the lie
with statistics to that you oughta let
you look at it's hilarious it's it's a
Darrell hospital he wrote it he shows
how old how to get how to how to get
people thinking that the data is
different from what it is like one of
the ones I remember is how he takes a
sacks of flour he's trying to show
something like you know sac fly that's
six inches hike and another one at seven
inches high something has gone up from
six to seven well when you see the sack
of flour that seven inches high it's a
three-dimensional object and so it's
really the ratio is 7 cubed to 6 cubed
which is much bigger than the ratio of
726 while the data was actually talking
about a number that went from seven to
six and so when you make these when you
make these charts you can also wrong it
can also confuse the issue but I will
cease what were some of them some of the
neat things like that he had in here was
a scatterplot he was able to put to put
to put words in among the data points in
a way that was reasonable that was kind
of interesting for for the
you know so you not only have a graph
but you have you have other things to
read here the length of an organism at
the time of reproduction related to the
generation time and so he has he has
some some some ideas for that that's
that people try something that worked on
it didn't work out too there's a funny
idea that people have to put it in two
phases have you seen this one where they
were let me see if i can find that do
they have faces here this night anyway
creatures were supposedly wired to be
able to ought to pick out features of
faces in certain ways and so they
thought they would present the data that
way let's see faces oh it wasn't have it
under faces friendly data graphics what
what's that friendly data graphics
versus unfriendly words are spelled out
mysterious and elaborate encoding
aborted unfriendly abbreviations abound
friendly words when from left to right
fun friendly were thrown vertically and
so on that's his idea okay and then he
has comment from josef albers who's the
the guy who's Vic who's da famous for
the alborz wall outside physics tank
here and surah nisa we're all one of the
big teachers of graphic design thank you
is yeah ok so here was this looks like a
chart that you seen this new york times
but this is I is this is a good some
good examples where you can where you
can combine syntax with semantics you
can get that you can get the blue the
you can you can see the picture and you
can also look at it further if you want
to if you want to get to the detail so
that was kind of so some good ideas in
here
what the place is oh yeah Tracy will
look for the faces well I'm joinha Terry
Winograd toward Terry's book language as
a cognitive process had difficult things
to describe he's talking about parsing
algorithms for English language here for
natural languages and and so he's got
some little little little charts and so
on but the main thing that he let's see
if I can he has his data structures are
described by little frames whatever we
call him and and he has these pictures
in here but let's see if I I got to find
the the way that he gives the the nested
structure which for chest if he had to
ok he's got things like this which shows
the way the way things map inside of
others inside of others so he's got he
but that's still data structure I got to
show the algorithm here he's got a
cursive transition networks let me see
where do we have some of the long ok hmm
well this is I think just by paging
through here you know you can you can
see the idea of how he's how he has oh
how he has got his algorithms described
by by giving exactly giving a lot of of
structured examples of how they of how
they work let me see now but I still
trying to look for the kinds of things
where he's actually got this maybe it's
later on in the book
hmm see here he's got diagrams of
sentences but that's that's not what I
wanted there maybe maybe it's all on one
page and I and I was the page I'm a
steady I should have looked it up before
class he's got he's got play by plays in
this you know to describe the algorithm
here but i but I I remember he had some
he wrote Oh a bunch of computer programs
that were able to do this indentation
you did this with with the very first of
the basic version of tech he broke it
all the time i added macro some kind of
macros just for him oh this is well this
is a grammar that he has here with you
see this is what tough calls not
user-friendly because it's going up and
going vertically i do not what tough to
boom
think the book was ok so this is I guess
this is the kind of thing that I'm
thinking of here where is just the way
he's got the the algorithm described
hierarchically in these in these parts
and that seems to that seems to work for
because he's describing a hierarchical
thing and he could do it instead of a
tree diagram you could do it with boxes
inside of boxes inside of boxes and get
the idea yeah here's his his way of
describing algorithms ok so it's like
that ok so did you find any faces oh ok
so let's see what
half faces carry the same information as
full faces they might be okay now no
somehow I don't see doing that in mind
oh this is pretty nice cartoon face is
okay this is a actually Herman chernof's
the idea he was a Stanford Roman sure
enough was a great loss to Stanford when
he went easy okay so so check so yeah oh
goodness using you the normal law of
error stands out the experience of
mankind oh well and Tracy found another
why she glued risk this was interesting
this is oh this is a different kind of
visiting to display data but this is to
show that the the places of where skin
cancer occurred on man's head and house
is throat and so showing it on on a
man's face that obviously a win with a
person space and these are our
supposedly you can learn to understand
these I have to I have to get interested
in the problem to want to know if it
works or not okay now let's see in my
own book I I think the most complicated
thing I had to get across was that it
was an elevator this is a this is an
example of a of a already called
multitasking or multi you know parallel
environment where a lot of things are
going on at once i'm simulating the
elevator system
at Caltech math building Tracy will
remember that elevator I rode up and
down the elevator with the stopwatch
keep taking notes calling the people now
push the button on the third floor and
you'll see what it does next elevator
system 280 okay and and so here I was
describing the bunch of co routines one
for the people who won for the elevator
and and then I i got the description
here to show which I I think people have
read this through I mean this is about
the only way I could think up to explain
what's happening but it's not
diagrammatic and I am so would be
interesting exercise for me to see
somebody go through and some graphic
designer to go through it and see if
they could figure out a way to present
this better but I I still at least I
could I could describe where I you know
what the time is on the clock and what
state the elevator is in what floor it's
at and where the doors are open and
what's step but were were while we're
executing and then there's different co
routines going on and seeing seeing
something this way best I could think of
in 1960s in the third volume I've got a
fold-out illustration which was which
was great fun especially to see how this
comes out in in many other languages
when they translate the book into other
languages I always turn first to the
fold out and see how they did it I think
this was ok work now took it took this
took me several weeks to draw it so I
should be able to find it if I look if I
look hard enough ah it's in this part
actually here we go so we got a diagram
like this now this one I think does does
convey something like they couldn't that
you could only otherwise dubai by
sitting and watching tape units winding
back and forth it's talking about how
the sort numbers on
on tapes and and I I discovered as
always writing this book that most of
the people who wrote papers about how to
sort on tapes had never seen that
process actually gone they were playing
some mathematical game but they didn't
realize it took time to rewind the tapes
and that there was certain overlaps and
buffering and things going on they had
these neat algorithms but when you
actually saw what happened it didn't
work that way so I wanted to give the
the feeling of reality so if you look at
if you look at this tape here there's
there's a code which indicates like this
this hash mark here means i'm reading
the data so off of to offer the sixth
tape i'm reading it and the black
markings I'm writing it and so I read
some data and I get I feel my memory and
I right oh this is a big this is a you
know a whole is a lot of data so this is
one memory load full of data and then I
distribute and this was this was Brand X
over this is the one that everybody
started with him and wanted to and and
you know we're improving on by their by
their other algorithms and you you you
go 123123123 until you get to the end
here then you rewind everything then
these dots mean Rio you can see the
takes quizzing backwards rewinding and
then you start reading from those three
tapes one two and three and they write
on two tapes by this time you know how
many records are they right a certain
number on the tape for and then rewind
tape for they are then they start
writing on tape five are this this this
circles here mean the operator is has to
go over to the tape end and dismount it
and put a scratch tape on because it was
the input tape you don't want to destroy
that and so you have to wait for that is
you know these practical considerations
are take power take place in this thing
so you're reading the data merging
things onto the the end of strings the
little white dots tell how long before
you have a break in this means its
ascending you can you can actually get
things that are longer than your memory
size in ascending order on these tapes
and then your third tape gets it by this
time it's all rewound and got a new
mounted and you can rewind it and we can
read from tapes four or five and six and
merge on the tape 1 2 3 and then and we
rewind again a little bit and so on and
finally we get the answer and here we
are and that is done int in 18 a little
less than 18 minutes okay now we take
the improved algorithm the polyphase
merge which was 46 tapes was considered
to be a big improvement well it is cool
it turns out that the polyphase merge
was waiting a long time for rewinds when
there was nothing possible to do because
you had to rewind a fairly long tape and
and so if you if you check it out even
though it was doing let it was supposed
to be a win according to the according
to the calculations in the paper in the
in the journals it actually took 18 and
a half minutes to do that well I was
supposed to be you know quite a bit
faster than the other ones because of
the rewind time and and not being able
to see a chart like this you wouldn't
get to see whether for the bottleneck
was there is another algorithm that was
that's the one of the first others to be
patented and it meant that nobody could
actually use it without paying a royalty
on it and this one was they thought it
was so good they would patent and that's
one at the bottom here i'm pleased to
say that that one that was the big loser
but of all and then by actually looking
at this data were able to come up with
some some algorithms that dumb that
avoided the wastage of time but this
this is this like this kind of a chart
now i took me a long time to prepare the
chart and it took addison-wesley they
had to farm it out to us to another
studio their regular artist you know
said nah I'm not gonna do this and so
they had somebody else do it
professionally now i would type sedative
court would would it wouldn't it
wouldn't take me as long i would get it
more accurate i have a computer program
generated and
oh wow so every problem seems to there's
there are a few general things that we
kept coming back to hear play by plays
see but but each each each algorithms
has its own domain that's going to
probably make you interesting in for
every paper you write that if you want
to figure out the best way to waited
this you not to do it you can only get
you can get out you can get ideas and
you get your mind off of off of the old
ways of doing it by reading a book like
this by seeing other papers but I don't
have a general recipe for how did you
know do through the optimum figure